no we're getting down to as the
referendum campaign entered the home
straight two of its protagonists entered
the TV state it is a campaign rising to
a crescendo when it comes to voting
government getting government she didn't
vote for I didn't vote for him but I'm
stuck with him
I just extend that's what happens in a
democracy do you agree with David
Cameron I was just going to make another
point no no no you agree with David
Cameron or not feel like Jeremy pipes
with Michael how I feel do you agree
with David Cameron or not well you're
more like Michael Howard it was a
suddenly strided finger-pointing
alistair darling a leader of the pro
union campaign against alex salmond
in mild mannered measure tone mode the
theatre of the two men going head to
head was new even if the subject matter
was not any eight-year-old can tell you
the flag of the country the capital of a
country and its currency and i presume
the flags desalter i assume our capital
will still be Edinburgh which you can't
tell us what currency we'll have we'll
keep the phone because it belongs to
Scotland as much as it belongs to
England it's our pound as well as your
phone it had been the day the main
Westminster parties guaranteed new tax
and spending powers to the Holyrood
Parliament after the 2015 general
election in debate the subject came up
give me two powers that will definitely
accrue both tax and increased power over
which isn't bent over income tax all of
it income tax the power project
imperative just two things happening
there is power already coming well
you've got power
- to vary the rate of income tax a snap
Paul immediately after the debate gave
darling victory by 56 to 44 how did the
voters in this ed drop policy it
there's too much better in event I think
they didn't really get into the roots of
really what people are wanting to know
and why every wounded tortured really
and when it came to the currency union
part are really challenged salmon than
that salmon was preferred darlings
approach throughout the day but it
hasn't change over I think like I'm
votin I'm going yes but never won salmon
there are six weeks to go until Scotland
makes a decision on his future if the
campaign had lacked intensity before
it's got it now James Matthews Sky News
Ed book